[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur sa vie à délier décrit le seul yab
chantait sol il ya un organisme au
service de l'habitat indigne et de leurs
occupants
ici à château la vallière en touraine
sayid bénéficiaires du rsa et père de
trois enfants demandent de l'aide
il est propriétaire de cette maison
acquise en location vente il ya quelques
mois 25000 euros
aujourd'hui il est submergé par l'
ampleur colossale des travaux lectrices
et lecteurs
là c'est effectivement pour mettre aux
normes
parce que ça devient urgent avec de
l'aluminium autour et à laitages
même constat dans la cuisine que ce soit
au niveau des compteurs au niveau des
câbles électriques
on voit vraiment que c'est super
dangereux mais qui plus est une plaque
comme celle là sur une multiprise qui
est branché sur les caps qui sont pas
l'air con pas l'air très grosse
salopette aux normes parce que
normalement comme ça c'est du simili
m'intéressait beaucoup plus gros que ça
donc
reste que les câbles fondée que ça
prenne feu il m'a dit voilà moi j'ai pas
les moyens je veux sincèrement j'ai pas
les moyens de refaire l'installation
électrique voilà ici c'est la chambre et
salle de bain on va dire c'est le seul
endroit de choix vous voyez l'état des
moisissures au sol ça reflète bien un
peu le fait qu'il faut absolument pièce
aérée oui parce qu'ailleurs c'est très
très humide pas de chauffage patron donc
le mérite et en plus on a le temps de se
gratter toute la nuit d'accord on peut
pas chauffé parce que j'ai des factures
d'électricité et non la suroccupation
des logements c'est un des critères qui
fait que le logement nous on va le
qualifier d'un simple et ce n'est pas
l'unique point de danger dans la chambre
familiale
les moisissures sont juste hauteur du
lit l'humidité arrive par le toit faute
d'isolation
alors après la visite vient l'heure du
bilan merci on a vu les l'interrupteur
n'existe plus les fils sont à nu suffit
d'avoir le mauvais réflexe au mauvais
moment et puis vous preniez une
châtaigne en terme de travaux forfaire
toute l'isolation de tout le logement
faut refaire toute l'électricité pour
refaire à peu près toute la plomberie
monsieur shabeela de ce que je peux voir
en premier est assez que effectivement
il est éligible
à diverses aides et
il va y avoir ensuite un dossier a monté
un plan de financement à faire les
diverses z a monté et a demandé et ça
c'est un peu le rôle qu'on va faire à sa
place donc on va être là pour la
compagnie du début à la fin des enfants
c'est difficile parce qu' il ait pas de
se plaindre on a froid on au froid et on
se dit on et des parents titre quoi
d'avoir choisi peut-être qu'on aurait
dépensé d'abord à eux avant de penser à
la maison donc on a même regretté
d'avoir créé cette maison on s'est dit
si on n'a pas n'aurait jamais dû voilà
ce qu on a fait nécessairement se
pensait pas que ça coûterait aussi cher
pour faire ces travaux là il ya un peu
de honte
ah oui tout à fait on a honte de dire
même là on est phénomène pas le choix
mais on se dit c'est bien pour les
autres ça va servir aussi ce qu'ils ont
du mal à le faire saïd lui s'est résolu
à demander de l'aide grâce à une
assistante sociale
comme souvent dans les cas de logements
insalubres parce que la principale
difficulté dans la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne c'est tout simplement
de le détecter pas facile en toile de
fond il y à la honte pour les occupants
de l'admettre ou juste la difficulté à
réaliser que son chez soi a subi les
ravages du temps à château-renault près
de tours les élus cette fois demande de
l'aide
et c'est toute une ville à se courir le
centre bourg souffrent les bâtisses et
frites
amélie vient diagnostic et l'insalubrité
de la commune avec madame le maire
alors du coup aujourd'hui on va partir
sur la rue principale de chateaurenaud
on va aller voir ce qu'on est impossible
et en logements vacants et en logements
insalubres
cette rue de la république qui a vieilli
des bâtisses anciennes y ont fait leur
temps sans jamais le moindre
rafraîchissement parmi elles plusieurs
biens communaux à repenser entièrement
d'abord passer par une étude de
faisabilité pour voir la faisabilité du
projet vous faire chiffrer les travaux
derrière c'est un coup corner pour la
commune ça ne vient pas forcément du
logement ça peut être aussi du commerce
a peut être l'installation en
équipements de service lutter contre
l'habitat indigne c'est l'une des
priorités de brigitte dupuis le début
d'un combat pour cette mère fraîchement
élue elle a d'ores et déjà porté une
opération de revitalisation de
territoire oui cette renault il ya du
nouveau ça va bouger ça va changer
et grâce aussi par sept à cette
réhabilitation de bâtiments sur sur
château renault toujours sur l'artère
principale quelques bâtiments plus loin
un second cas critiques
vu de l'extérieur wald dégradation du
bâti et pour que derrière il faut
pouvoir rentrer dedans et voir ce qui se
passe alors soit le logement est vacant
et du coup c'est beaucoup plus simple
on va dire de qualifier le logement
insalubre parce que du coup derrière ces
deux-là vacances si le logement est
occupé là c'est plus compliqué parce
qu'il faut pouvoir rentrer avec la
personne et l'occupant à l'intérieur du
logement
et ça passe par le biais de travailleurs
sociaux bien souvent qu'ils nous aident
à rentrer dans le logement
mais écoutez je vous remercie en tout
cas de la visite des six détecté pour
mieux combattre l'habitat insalubre
c'est une nécessité
en région centre val de loire on compte
5 % de logements potentiellement
indignes où vivent des familles des
enfants première victime avec des
conséquences parfois lourdes sur la
santé on est complètement rejoint savez
je fais la définition c'est la
définition est bien sa teinte une
atteinte au niveau de la santé de la
personne
ouais mais on arrive dans la salle de
bain ça c'est une salle de bains
lancement vous le dit ouais la
moisissure un moisissures terrible aussi
qu'est ce que ça peut faire sur
l'organisme d'un pays qui dans la
moisissure c'est quelque chose de
volatiles qui est très très faim c'est
vraiment une densité très très fine et
donc ça vole ça va voler ça va est
inhalée au niveau des enfants et ça va
déclencher des de la semaine franchit
tasmanie forme et puis voir après une
maladie asthmatique tout l'enfance et
avec des traitements des traitements
lourds souvent base de cortisone
on va traiter la phase aiguë mais en
chronique on peut rien faire il faut
changer de logement
nous ce qu'on va faire c'est le moment
on va traiter quand les enfants sont pas
bien où les adultes sont pas bien les
adultes auront plutôt des problèmes de
sinusite un petit peu mais les enfants
ça va être pharyngite otites grand
classique
puis on va les voir très régulièrement
tous les quinze jours tous les bijoux
les enfants trouvent des petites ses
écailles de peinture vont aller manger
pour les ingérer vont faire tout ce
qu'on appelle la maladie d'intoxication
au plomb c'est le saturnisme avec des
troubles psychologiques retard mental
retard psychomoteur et ça on guérit part
qu'on n'a pas de traitement contre ce
problème donc servi après donc c'est
vrai que c'est des conséquences très
importantes
même la médecine a ses limites alors
deux solutions s'offrent aux occupant
leur logement ou la réalisation de
travaux d'ampleur cher souvent bien trop
cher pour les propriétaires mais s'ils
répondent aux critères d'insalubrité et
que leur situation financière les
empêche d'en sortir
solia sollicite des financeurs parmi eux
l'anah l'agencé nationale de l'habitat
un établissement public qui peut
subventionner 60% des travaux s'ils
enveloppe totale des rénovations
n'excède pas 50 mille euros un premier
gros coup de pouce mais déjà sur une
enveloppe un volume d' assez conséquents
complétés par les collectivités locales
qui peuvent être les communautés de
communes le conseil départemental la
métropole comme c'est le cas sur la
métropole pour arriver un taux des deux
de plus proche de ce qu'il y est
soutenable pour le ménage avec un reste
à charge qui peut être plus résiduelles
possible mais malgré les subventions le
reste à charge de plusieurs milliers
d'euros demeure parfois trop onéreux
pour les propriétaires c'est donc
finalement la fondation abbé pierre qui
intervient avec le programme sos taudis
indispensable pour mener le projet de
travaux à son terme il est 300 ménages
par an en france
il ya des personnes qui faute de moyens
pour se loger correctement et face à
l'augmentation des loyers et à la crise
du logement
ils vont se dire ben pourquoi pas
acheter quelque chose mais ils vont
tomber sur des biens qui sont dégradées
ils vont penser que c'est une solution
est en fait ça va être une vraie
solution pour eux ça c'est un premier
profil si on peut dire et un deuxième
qui est très largement représentées dans
les personnes qu'on va aider ces des
personnes âgées en milieu rural les la
maison qui va être vêtu sait qu'il va
s'user
au fur et à mesure des années comme dans
ce cas récents en indre et loire
une retraitée seul dans une propriété
presque à l'abandon ces personnes
accompagnées des personnes en situation
de pauvreté par les autres
non il faut être très clair là dessus on
va calculer aussi quels sont ses
ressources et comment elle peut s'en
sortir
est-ce que c'est soutenable pour elle ce
plan de travaux et la fondation va dire
ben écoutez cette personne à le rendre
vraiment dans les critères de notre
programmation est audi il faut qu'on
l'aide
et il faut que ce programme de travaux
aille au bout
[Musique]
grâce à la fondation abbé pierre mais
aussi aux subventions des pouvoirs
publics et au soutien de sonia gail
cette retraitée à et peigner les bois en
touraine retrouve petit à petit ses
marques dans sa maison désormais digne
[Musique]
et ils ont installé à chauffage
rayonnant dans cette pièce dans la
chambre des enfants et dans la cuisine
et ils ont remplacé le petit lumière que
j'avais là-bas et ils ont installé cet
illustre que j'avais ensuite ils ont
fait le dallage par terre ici c'est un
attelage spécial pour ne pas glisser
plus aucun point de danger dans cette
maison mais toute la décoration reste à
faire et les projets ne manquent pas la
chambre sera cooller beurre frais rien
d'autre je veux la lumière j'ai déjà eu
bleus fut mon premier appartement quand
j'étais mariée la chambre était bleu
gitane
la cuisine était rouge la salle de bains
jaunes donc maintenant ça c'est clair ça
va réfléchir la lumière ça va très bon
j'espère cook est compliquée les clés à
rêver à l'extérieur c'est la toiture qui
a été complètement remplacer les tuiles
tombées là le faîtage aussi tombait
partout des deux côtés c'était vraiment
très très très pas simplement moche mais
comme il pleuvait à l'intérieur c'était
pas très sain non plus je n'aurais
jamais pu faire aucun des travaux j'ai
une toute petite retraite n'ont pas tout
petit j'ai une petite retraite qui me
suffit pour vivre mais je n'aurais
jamais pu faire faire des travaux
une facture totale autour des 50000
euros des semaines de chantier
d'investissement de générosité et au
bout pour gail le cadeau inestimable de
vivre enfin chez elle je crois que je
commence à penser que ma maison et
bientôt à ma hauteur
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que elle
commence à me refais le thé avant non
pas du tout c'est pas encore ça mais ça
que ça commence c'est quoi une maison
qui vous ressemble
[Musique]
élégant même si je ne suis pas là là je
suis ont retrouvé la confiance faire
rejaillir l'étincelle l'espoir et
redonner vie à un bâti délabrée par les
années offrir la sécurité du cocon
soigner les blessures du mal-logement
encore et davantage c'est la longue
route vers la dignité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]